you may have seen this video it was
going viral this is really wild it's
from the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC and there is a host on
the network I had never heard of her
before this her name is Yasmin visigoyan
and she apparently was not on air for a
couple weeks and then came back two days
ago to explain
why she hasn't been on air and this is
just incredible
I know from my Twitter feed that many of
you have wondered why I have been off
the air for a little while well I have
been dealing with a little bit of a
health scare on December 20th I began to
feel chest pains and they waxed and
waned over a period of 10 days I wasn't
quite sure what to make of it but as
they continued to get worse I started to
think something was actually wrong
um it was December 30th when I finally
went to an urgent care and was told I
had reflux I didn't really buy it but I
was relieved it wasn't my heart my body
though was pretty certain not to believe
the reflux the next day on December 30th
I woke up with severe pains both in my
chest and in my left shoulder and it was
like a tightening in my chest when I
took deep breaths that got worse when I
was laying flat
I knew enough at that moment to
understand that it could mean could is
the keyboard here that I was having a
heart attack especially because it was
happening the left part of my shoulder I
want to remind you I run seven miles
three to four times a week where I did
um I do yoga I don't eat meat I don't
smoke I drink occasionally not right now
though because my doctor tells me I
can't aside from probably not getting
enough sleep and working too much I'm a
pretty healthy person but on that day I
was anything but my husband drove me to
the emergency room and from there the
nightmare that has been my January began
I was diagnosed with pericarditis
inflammation of the lining of my heart
brought on by a virus a literal common
cold they determined I had developed
myocarditis inflammation of the actual
heart now the heart muscle
okay first off I wish her well I don't
know who she is I don't wish her ill uh
she is she is twice vaxxed and there she
is having this uh
this admission of what's been going on
with her why she wasn't on air okay
that's fine
um she is claiming that her doctor is
telling her that she got myocarditis and
the lining of the heart that's now
having issues that she got that through
the common cold
have any of you ever heard of this
before covid
that people who had a common cold
suddenly had these heart issues
no you have not I have not it did not
exist
she is twice vaxxed we do know that
especially with young men who are vaxxed
the rates of myocarditis are up
something like 78 and all sorts of heart
problems and you've seen all the videos
of people just dropping dead on soccer
fields and walking down the street and
all this weird stuff
so I cannot speak precisely to her
medical condition but does that not
strike you as the perfect level of
propaganda for MSNBC which is absolutely
100 percent a propaganda Network that
this woman who got twice vaxed does not
link this
to the vaccines it somehow is because of
the common cold
[Music]